senator ted cruz was in washington today
for the confirmation hearing of merrick
garland
cruz as we all know still facing huge
backlash
for his decision to go to cancun mexico
while texas was going through freezing
temperatures that knocked out
the entire state's power grid cruz's
reputation really took a hit
and you know it's a shame senator cruz
could have avoided
all that embarrassment if he had just
used
the cancun channel cold texas
weather got you down want to go to
cancun but don't want to be seen going
then all aboard the cancun tunnel the
high-speed tramway designed by
elon musk not that elon musk hi
my name is also elon musk we took the
hidden tunnels made by drug lord el
chapo
and turned them into a secret
underground tramway that starts 200 feet
under austin texas and rockets you at
1200 miles an hour
directly into the lobby of the
ritz-carlton hotel in cancun
still worried about being seen choose
one of our three disguises to hide your
identity
bearded biker dude cookie grandma
or sitting u.s senator the cancun
channel
que bueno sorry no pets